Fuckers.
Wait,
we sound the audio?
No,
just split it.
Split the audio.
This is over time,
folks.
This is part two.
We're talking about the differences.
Why is it okay?
You got to make it sure
I have a beer.
Yeah,
sure.
Man.
Go in there.
There's all kinds of shit in there.
There's all kinds of booze.
Oh yeah.
Always tell you to the right.
You know what?
If you see a brother and hulk,
coconut water,
he's fucking with them.
Don't let them do it.
And sometimes
he'll hang onto that for five minutes to,
you'll tap
any problems.
Get the weirdest sense of humor.
It's funny as hell.
He throws people off track.
You don't know him?
No.
Throw me off track.
The other day was fucking Joey Diaz.
Taxi scared me.
Hold on.
I want to,
don't say this until we go back on.
Jamie,
we're not recording,
are we?
Are we recording?
Yes,
we are right now.
Okay,
go ahead.
Sorry.
Coconut water.
Oh,
give me one of them.
Jammies too.
Thank you,
sir.
You know they're better.
And the boxes,
not the cans.
No,
no,
no.
C Two o is the best.
100%.
You know why this is Thai coconuts?
It's a different taste.
I get it,
but when he goes into the cans,
I heard it kills the nutrition.
Oh,
a thousand.
This is all the [inaudible] most
of that's been killed anyway,
Bro.
Science,
where'd you get this?
Science is this,
this is
fucking Vegas is crumbling.
$400 million dividend for the city center.
So it's making a lot of money.
Doesn't mean it's not getting torn down.
It's getting torn down.
Nothing.
I read Yahoo News every morning,
man.
Like a fucking shark.
Like it's my job.
Oh,
you questioning young Jamie's
googling skills a little bit.
Whoa.
He's taking his shirt off.
I was trying to scare you.
Look at you getting angry.
He got angry.
He hooked out.
He's upset.
You were taking the fresh,
it's delicious.
Right?
C Two O it's so much better
than any other coconut water.
Uh,
we,
you know who,
uh,
I think it was Earl Warren had these,
it was,
he brought a man.
Why don't you guys brought these in?
I just,
how I found out about [inaudible] oh,
we were training and um,
they had g day,
you know how you used to do gay day.
Do you guys still do that?
Sometimes.
Once a year.
The old legends we
stopped and this is like,
you know,
coconut waters,
like what?
The Brazilians have been known to drink.
So one of the dudes,
um,
that was training brought in a
massive coconut water just for fun.
Like,
because like it's ski day and my friend,
we want to train like Buddhists.
Elian.
That's cool.
What you found it?
What is it?
Hotel?
What does it say?
The Harmon hotel,
which I was part of the city of center,
it never opened it.
It's going to be torn down in two weeks.
Demolition never opened Harmon
hotel to begin in two weeks.
Oh,
mark.
Good instructors all fucked up,
right?
Oh boy.
That's not the whole city center.
It's just one.
It's like a comp call.
The whole thing real quick.
Eddie,
I exaggerate everything right?
But let's see a picture of it.
Which one is it?
You're the to the left of the Aria side.
Oh my God.
Look at this size of it,
dude.
Fuck dog.
The size of it.
They get a tear.
That whole thing down.
Yeah,
like not safe for people.
Oh my God.
Wrapped in black netting prior.
What does that say prior to demolition.
Oh my God.
That's why it's wrapped in black netting.
Whew.
Ooh.
Imagine if you have the
hotel next to it and like,
don't worry dude.
We're not even scratch your shit.
Just like guide all right
next to your Porsche and say,
hey bro,
I'm going to blow up my car,
but I'm going to put a net over yours.
Just be cool.
Don't sweat it.
I'm just going to blow
it up right next to you.
Shit.
They should have.
They should build up a
solid steel enclosure.
Blow it up and then dispose of rock.
Can you imagine for the
engineer looking at this,
it says here,
he said it was originally to have arisen
49 floors as a show piece of the city
center,
which opened just as Nevada was
entering the depths of the recession,
the 4,000 room,
Aria resort and casino along
with the Mandarin Hotel.
Fewer than 400 rooms and the all suite
57 story Vadera open within a month of
each other.
But the Harmon stage shuttered.
It wasn't a recession,
but construction issues that
kept the harm and clothes.
It's construction plan was eventually
scaled down by almost half,
but then concerns remained that
it would topple in an earthquake.
Oh Wow.
I knew it while I'm Macau hotel supposed
to open there soon in a big area that's
been under development for
over like 10 years in Vegas.
I watched a documentary about,
it's probably talking about some of this.
Um,
uh,
I think it's like the
MGM crew or one of them.
I don't want to say who
because I don't know exactly,
but uh,
they were developing a huge thing
and it fell apart basically.
And she had been sitting empty for 10
years and this Macau company is moving in
and it's supposed to open
up and about a year or so,
if it's not opening sooner than that,
a big multibillion dollar Asian hotel
that all these McCowen Chinese people were
supposed to come in and Save Vegas.
Well,
crazy.
Would it be if Vegas got
taken over by Chinese,
they came in guns blazing and just
built some unbelievable hotels because
they're written money over there.
Just true written money.
So it was my man Donald Trump though.
Yet before bullies get the fuck
outta here with all that nonsense.
Donald Trump can hang with the triads.
They're going to come over here with a
giant space ships zeppelins filled with
diamonds,
just rained them down on Las Vegas.
We're going to build a building
made of entirely of diamonds,
all filled with hookers,
all filled with 10 side meet the Alpha,
drive everybody around it or Rolls Royce.
No one's going to go to any other casino.
You're going to take it to
the most ultimate level ever.
I'm not mad at that if cause it.
Macau really is what they say it is.
If it really is 10 times Vegas,
that means they're making 10
times as much money as vague.
Remember that joke says,
Sam
per bleed said that.
Uh,
it was something about how girls will
always be with the guys with money.
No matter what.
Girl doesn't have a recession
for hot Darth Vader.
Darth Vader can come down takeover and,
and I'm,
I'm killing the joke,
but it was one of the Best Sam Tripoli,
Tripoli dead on.
Yeah,
I remember.
I can't do it today.
You see some ugly as
dudes with harness chicks.
That's true.
The only reason you guys got mad paper.
Mad Paper makes up for a lot of things.
There's hope for every man out there.
If you're an unattractive woman,
mad paper gets you a gay guy
pretending to be straight.
I ain't that a bitch.
That's what you get.
If you look like a warlock as a
girl and you're a millionaire,
you think Bruce Jenner
was kind of like that?
No,
no,
no.
I think if you live with
crazy bitches on enough,
you become one.
No.
Did you know Bruce Jenner said he's always
felt like a woman even when he was a
kid,
he's always felt like it was gay.
It turns out he's gay the whole time.
No,
he's not gay.
He's just felt like he's in a man's body.
The crazy thing about a lot of these
people that become transgender,
there's this like there's so many
different possibilities when it comes to
sexuality.
Wait a minute,
that still like checks.
That's something that a lot of us have
a hard time accepting because we only
have our own version of
sexuality and gender,
but some people are men.
They're attracted to women,
but they're attracted to women and wish
they were a woman and we're in love with
a woman as a lesbian.
They will sacrifice their dick.
They'll sacrifice the ability to come.
They'll sacrifice their testicles,
they'll sacrifice testosterone,
they'll sacrifice their male
gender and still be with women.
Bro,
I got one for you.
Have you heard of lady valor?
Yeah,
the fucking navy seal.
This badass navy seal.
Who said he,
he,
she,
she likes me.
She,
so he was a navy seal from seal team one
to seal team six and then he was just
like,
you know what?
I've always wanted to be
a woman my entire life.
I felt like a woman.
Straight dude.
Now you know,
you know like trying to look
like a woman in a dress.
Polka dot dress looks like me.
Really Tattoos and shit.
Mascara on.
Teach another navy seals
how to shoot and shit.
Is there a chance or a chance that the
Bruce Jenner thing could be a situation
where he's coming out slowly?
Cause remember Elton John was,
he looked totally gay.
He was flaming but he denied it.
He was managing,
he said he was bi and
then now he's full game.
So he came out first.
They came out where he is by,
he didn't come out fully all the way.
And so maybe Bruce Jenner's like,
you know,
and I can't come out and say I'm
gay and I want to be a woman.
Let me tell people I want to be a woman
first and then laid or Morrissey saying,
Oh,
I'm not gay,
I'm asexual.
That's what he said.
He said he's asexual.
Bruce Jenner sat down with one of
those fucking interviews and it's,
I just read some details about it.
He's coming out and saying,
I felt like a woman my entire life.
I believe that.
Why you leave out?
Why
would you doubt that
someone would be asexual?
Cause then a lot of ways Stan hope
is asexual at this point in his life.
He doesn't have sex anymore.
He's still a man,
but he doesn't have sex anymore.
Maybe it doesn't,
it doesn't get hard anymore.
Not Interested in his testosterone,
just so I can just booze.
Damn booze and cigarettes
while he's having a great time.
Doesn't care.
Yeah.
Have a great live in life.
Loves it.
Teach though.
He's not,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He's having a good time.
I'm serious.
He talks about it openly.
He's like,
he's,
he's down with the slide.
Wow.
Yeah,
so there's different people,
man.
Everybody's different.
I mean,
Stan is not the dummy.
He's,
that's just what his decision,
he doesn't care.
And there's some people that you know,
like they might be asexual,
Marcy might be asexual.
That might not be bullshit.
It might be just this
is how he is the eye,
if everybody,
have you heard some of the smiths songs?
Thankfully,
thankfully,
no.
Okay.
I've heard a few of them,
but they made me sad.
I just only getting sad.
You know there's there,
is it all about having sex with dudes?
No.
You could just,
I don't think I've heard the songs.
You haven't heard of Smith Smith,
the smiths with Morrissey,
the singer?
Oh No.
How old are you again?
31 okay.
It's before your time.
It's like the cure,
the passion mode,
Morrissey,
all the,
I thought we're talking kind of easy,
like just hip hop everything.
I listen to everything.
Do you know this guy?
And he was such a rabid Vegan,
not a catch.
He won't let anybody who works for him.
He won't let anybody who
works for meet meet this guy.
Yeah.
When people working from like the crew,
he won't let them eat meat like he,
he like if you worked for him on tour,
you cannot eat meat.
Oh fuck.
That's a fucking,
these guys get together and we'll,
the idea that he could dictate
what someone's died is.
It's hilarious.
But he controls not just their
physical body when they work for him,
but what they put in their body
when they're on tour with him,
he does not allow them to eat meat.
So the crew,
they get together in one hotel room,
they'll find,
pick a hotel room and they ordered
room service and just go off and have
cheeseburgers and steak and shit and
they have to hide it from Morrison here.
This just her from some
kid that told Brennan shop.
I did tell me though,
it was a roadie
who heard it from Brendan
shot then I've heard the band.
I heard it from the guy who
actually worked for him.
The guy was a Rodeo.
Well,
he,
you know,
he really feels strongly about it.
Like say if you hired a bunch of people
and you found out that they like to eat
babies,
he'd be like,
look man,
you can't fucking eat babies
if you want to work for me.
I don't get,
maybe babies is a little different,
but the idea is just so he's so anti
animal cruelty that he doesn't want anyone
around him working in any
capacity that kills animals.
He feels like they're murderers.
I mean,
I don't agree with them,
but that's where it comes from.
If you found out already eight baby dogs,
would you let him open for you?
I would try to
Benson the naughty baby
dogs after the talk was,
I get a logical argument.
What is a lamb?
What does lamb?
Lamb is a baby sheet.
Exactly.
Mutton is a sheep.
I don't fuck with lamb either.
Lamb has doors.
I don't fuck with landlord veal chops.
I love lamb chops.
Unfortunately I don't,
I don't eat veal.
Veal cancels Gig in Iceland after
venue refuses to go vegetarian,
so he wants everyone to go vegetarian.
No hot dog is this singer.
Was due to perform it,
the Harper concert hall and
Reggie Avik and Iceland around.
He's still a rock star.
Look at Mick Jagger,
but listen to it loosened this.
It was this request.
Iceland doesn't have any fucking ground.
You can grow vegetables in Asshole,
like you can't be a vegetarian Iceland
unless you're bringing in trucks,
load of food or unless you've got some
sort of a crazy fucking greenhouse in
there.
Now look at that face right there.
You'd think he's asexual and I like guys,
he's Asexual,
but I shall leave the Harpa concert hall
to they're cannibalistic flesh eating
blood lust.
Marcy said in a statement,
quick,
fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy.
Real quick,
real quick.
I love Iceland.
Have wanted to for a long time to return.
That's hilarious.
Is this recent?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
What?
Not what?
February.
Wow.
Really recent.
He's a nut bag.
Germany.
He walked off the stage.
I think it's Poland show
after being heckled by a fan.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's like a real still
claiming a sexuality.
Do you know why you care?
He's like,
I don't know if this guy
wants to fuck or not.
He might be saying yes.
The other dude's
trying to fuck her.
He's like so hung up on
the guy being asexual.
I just think he's lying
because of it.
Yeah,
I think he's sucking Dick.
What makes you say that though,
Marcy?
Unfortunately I am not a homosexual.
Wow.
You know what,
man?
This is what I think,
dude.
He's a human sexual.
Exactly.
Humus,
human sexual.
I think he just eats salary.
Your fucking Dick don't work no more.
I agree.
I got it.
I was like
fucking commentators were
commentating on biology.
I agree.
If you have too much
capital for the record,
my favorite singer of all time is crazy
gay and it makes no difference to me,
but no,
no need to talk about names.
The guys that have come
out like Rob Halford,
I love rob,
famous guy.
Rob Helfer is one of the
most famous singers ever.
He's awesome.
He's openly gay.
He came out,
he says,
I still listen to Judas priest.
I don't give a shit.
Oh guys,
I could give two shits.
Jedi makes no difference.
I've just,
you know,
just don't,
I would say if you want to
know if it has sex with this,
come out,
don't lie.
You know what?
I think,
man,
I think my blues fans,
the people that care about that,
there's less of them in less than them
every day and I think we just hang in
there and we just hang in
there as a civilization.
I think racism,
I think people that are homophobic,
transsexual,
phobic or transphobic or
whatever they call it,
people will give a fuck what anybody does.
Loan.
It doesn't hurt you or,
or other folks.
They're going to go away.
They're not going to be around anymore.
I think.
Yeah,
I think this is all just a blip
in our evolution and our learning.
How long,
how long do you think,
how many hundred years at least?
At least no,
no racism.
A hundred years,
no homophobia.
A hundred years.
All of it.
It'd be out the window.
There'll be like a little blips here
and there that'll shock the shit out of
people will find out that there's still
people that they're terrible at raising
children,
but I think 100 years is several
generations in the future.
That's two,
three,
four,
whatever the fuck it.
What's a generation?
What's the technical generation?
20 how many years?
Five years now,
but I don't think they
consider a generation 75 years.
I think it's like a 10 or 20
year period that they called you,
like how long it is before if you're born
where you can start fucking and having
kids like how long.
I think that's what they
think of as a generation.
I don't think it's a full life one.
Life's Mexico's 16 ah,
how dare you.
How dare you?
How long has the generation roughly
as the average period,
but 25 years in their offspring.
That's all it said.
20 it says right here in general,
we think of a generation as being 25
years from the birth of a parent to the
birth of a child.
Damn,
he's hookers or getting pregnant quick.
25 already having kids.
Give yourself a chance,
girl,
go get a life.
Go around.
See the world.
I'll watch that shit
on 16 pregnant though.
Do you?
You know when I watched the other day
that I got obsessed with is that Goddamn
addiction.
My strange addiction show.
Let's get you watched five
of those fuckers in a row.
The mattresses?
Yeah,
the bitch snacks on mattresses.
You see this now?
It's been five different ones though.
Then she ate her entire mattress,
then went to her moms.
Oh my God.
The mattress cookie monster.
This monster.
That was another eating
disorder one there too.
We're all eating.
Oh my God.
She's eating a mattress.
Shits.
Look at her house.
The calories.
The one above it.
A faithful mattress and what does
that chick drinking gasoline.
Yeah,
she's drinking.
Guess what about the girl
with a giant titties?
She's eating matches my addiction to teal.
What is she saying?
Women has spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars on the surgery ones crazy too.
What does she done to herself,
Jamie?
We needed to know.
Obviously she hasn't gotten a boob job.
Oh,
I saw a girl the other day that
was into eating those dryer sheets.
Oh yeah.
I saw that bitch and they were too strong.
So what she would do is you're too strong.
She would wrap them and toilet paper,
fold them up and eat the dryer sheets.
Dude,
that one you skip by the fucking guy.
Uh,
his girlfriend is his car.
He makes love to his car
now.
They showed him that full,
it's like dry humping the
car and get a 98 Monte Carlo.
What do you expect?
You would fucking 98 Monte Carlo,
right?
This is fucking American
paper as a kid ball,
but every paper,
no.
Oh my God.
Look at her.
Ted's 38.
K.
She's uh,
she's Ku Klux Klan.
She just wanted to get to
k because it's a KKK thing.
That'd be fun for a night.
Then you wake up,
the next one be like,
this is fucking weird dude.
Or implants or 14 pounds.
That would not be fun.
I think you'd be surprised.
I think it'd be a hell of a time.
Well if you're scared,
if you're scared,
I 100% get it.
She couldn't complain about
you putting it in her ass.
That's true.
She's got 14 pound implants.
I mean she could take someone conference,
get a certain size.
It's a turnoff.
Really?
Yeah.
There's a number of two giant,
it's like raw crazy chick
digging in her ears.
Oh,
you're talking about like 12 hours a week
or scrapes or ear canal with scissors.
Oh my God.
Nail files and other sharp
objects until she bleeds.
Whoa.
There was a chickie weights.
So
Jesus Christ had staff.
Ooh,
they get in her ears.
Could you date?
Could you,
could you put up with it if a chick
was eaten mattress all the time.
But she's just a fucking smoke show.
You just what?
She's eating your matches when she comes
over and let her know that you can't do
that in front of me.
So she's like,
so you're watching TV shoot.
She goes,
I'll be right back.
He touch half of your monitors.
Dope mattress.
It smells like lavender.
Five ounces a day.
This guy was snow snort and baby powder.
That's he stay alive.
Well,
maybe that's like what everybody has
always been snorting everywhere when they
thought they were getting cocaine,
they weren't true and this
guy found a cheaper way.
The addiction began one day afterwards.
A woman after she spilled baby powder
and inhaled it by mistake over the last
decade,
it escalated.
She loves the sensation and now
instead of just sniffing the powder,
j shoves it up her
nostrils 12 times a day.
What?
I mean,
what's the side of her dude?
Five ounces is a lot of baby powder.
A lot.
A pound is 16 ounces.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
This is Norton.
A third of a pound mean.
What if she's just doing this
to cover up a coke problem
that's got this problem
with the [inaudible]?
Just fucking,
she could always,
if she gets busted with coke,
it was,
no,
it's baby pedago fuck you.
And then you just send her a link.
Click on that link.
Strange addiction.
It's some weird shit,
man.
Is that an ABC show?
Why is it on abc.com oh,
it's in the news.
What if like every fifth line it's coke.
He just,
she just mixes it.
Just like tricking people.
That girl,
she snorts mothballs.
Oh God.
There's so many.
Oh,
this one was,
see the one with the glasses,
the far left.
This is a crazy one.
I watched this one the other day.
Let me tell you something.
She's an adult baby.
She's transgender.
She was born a boy,
decided wanted to be a girl,
a wears diapers and pajamas.
Likes to be a baby.
Where's pigtails?
How old is she likes to pee her pants.
She loves to pee your pants.
That's not it.
That's not the one that was good.
She says,
biting into a fucking rock.
Oh,
your teeth.
He goes,
yeah,
she's eating raw,
but we all know in your life we've all
met someone who was so fucking crazy go.
You know,
I think it's real.
Widow eats her husband's
ash and I've seen that.
That's sad.
That one's super dark.
That's dark baby feeding adult babies.
Oh,
shed.
Click the the one of the gate and
rocks and look at her a baby pouches.
That's cold
baby powder.
My well,
he sent it to me.
This guy is really fucking his car.
It's just bad.
Is that a dude was in
love with real dolls.
Let's see that.
So can we click on that?
Can we click on it?
I want to see the real dolls.
Oh my God.
He has a couple too.
It was just a picture.
We'll,
we'll just guarantee you could find it
or a video somewhere or available online.
It's chugging gasoline.
How the fuck are you alive?
This girl's eating cat food.
Well that's just protein.
The cat food is the least impressive.
Yeah,
the cat food.
It's like eating a mattress.
Just next level shit.
Hatchery system matches to some
shit and she devoured that thing.
Ah,
there was another one that was a pro
body builder or a woman who's addicted to
bodybuilding.
Does she?
What does she addicted to?
What is she doing?
Looking sexy as fuck barf.
She's got a little cat turds coming out
of her mouth and she just dropped some
things between her titties,
man.
Yeah,
cat turds.
She's got a whole mouth full of them.
You're gonna stick your Dick in there.
This is the one the I'm
addicted to being an adult baby.
That might be the worst one.
You're a drinker.
Weird one man.
The baby one was really weird because
I saw her at point a lot of things.
She was talking about how good it
must feel to pee into the diaper.
And I was like,
damn,
I bet that does feel good.
She was like the feeling of
release and then the warmth,
wetness of the diaper right away.
I can get that.
I can see that.
It can feel like you're talking to
people and just like embrace it.
Just spiking.
I take those gorilla piss though,
man.
That shit good.
It's dorm.
It's all of your balls for
about 10 seconds and then
you start smelling ammonia.
Here we go.
Oh,
okay.
And he still loves his real dog.
What does that mean still?
They got in a fight.
Well there's a whole,
you gotta be a weird fucking dude man.
We'll do Dube.
She has kind of hot though who she,
but he's like in full play mode.
Like he pretends that it's a real person.
She's out of his leg.
Can you though,
if you,
if a real woman was so far out of your
reach that this was the alternative.
You look behind that guy,
back that up a second.
Look behind that guy on the shelf.
What does that,
is that all porn?
That's exactly what that is.
Look at that.
That mother paused.
That shit right there.
That's foreign.
I guess like their DVDs.
The fuck has DVDs.
True.
It's 2015 DVD collection link that
this fucking dude is jack in it.
Those are DVDs of porn.
That's the only thing that
sells and deviation day.
If it wasn't for porn DVDs,
it'd be off the market.
They wouldn't even have to be because
these bitches be eight tracks.
They just copy.
They want,
they want blue ray,
they want HD.
They want it to be able to pause the
remote and they don't want the government
to know that downloading it.
Wow.
You've given me,
they got a shitty Internet connection.
Okay.
Maybe they don't want their jack and
to be dependent upon their Internet
connection.
True.
You know it's on your phone.
That guy's whacking it for sure.
Well,
he's not,
he's puking his real doll.
Right?
He must've just got
turned down so many times.
He's like,
fuck this noise.
He might not have even made a swing.
He might not have even never stepped
to the plate and I can look it up.
It looks like he swung it at some dicks.
Let's be honest here.
Would that haircut like
that and better and better?
You know what's hilarious about the show
is this fucking counselor guy that has
to come in and talk to each
person has an addiction.
Whether it's a guy or a Gal.
If there's some,
there's different counselors all the time.
What does this guy singer,
what could he possibly,
you don't think he's like,
motherfucker.
You don't look at them.
Know.
I know this is fucking weird.
Look at the camera setup.
How low tech is this show?
They've got a GoPro behind
that dude's right shoulder.
I'm serious.
They're on TV.
Look at that Gopro.
That's,
that's the video we're watching.
We're watching GOPRO video.
Fuck,
look at this dude.
He's in love though,
but they get this counselor that
comes in and pretends he's got it.
She got a dog collar on it because a deck,
if he's happy,
the WHO gives a fuck.
Like you're bringing a counselor and
he looks at these put collars on her.
Yeah,
that is weird.
Owns those checks he has.
Good.
That's a good memory.
I think I saw a couple man just back that
up real quick and you see exactly what
it looks like.
He's fucking it.
Not right there.
Watch when you see a face to
face Rose McGowan a little bit,
but not real.
Watch this.
When you see him like
face to face with it.
Yeah.
We're at that phase of life.
That's the fuck face chewing gum.
Chewing Gum,
slinging Dick on her.
I'm not going to lie.
It looks at you as a pizza
humped over like a letter c
jumbo shrimp.
What do you think the
average year as general
in prison were you at 40 50 60 years
where I'll you suppress your sexuality so
much that you start thinking about dudes.
A couple hours a day I'll
give a damn and they're like,
you know what,
I'm just gonna start sucking.
Did you see the picture of this?
It's a controversial picture that's been
going around lately of these two guys
that are standing up and they've got a
belt around this dude's knack and then
dudes on his knees and he's got a black
eye and they're like making gang signs
in front of the camera.
It's pretty,
it's awesome.
It's pretty crazy man.
See if he could put on Jamie,
hold on,
let me explain it to Jamie stories.
Surgeon it,
there's um,
two dudes that are stand to,
to young African American fellows that
are throwing up gang signs and in front
of them is a dude who was on his knees
and he's got a belt around his neck and a
black eye and the dude was doing eight
years I think for armed robbery or
something along those lines.
And um,
apparently there is beating his ass and
making them their dog or whatever the
fuck they want to do with them.
Well this is a picture.
They took him prison,
prison,
somebody like tweeted it or something.
They do,
man,
they told me,
Doug,
they have phones,
they get phones in there,
they get all kinds of drugs in there.
That's it.
That's the picture.
Look at this Georgia gang launch
attack on what does it say?
God Damn.
It's crazy.
Is there a worst job in the
world like gimp in prison?
Mom's furious.
Teen men launch gang attack
on her son 18 to prison cell,
then tie a leash around his neck and
pose for a Facebook photo despite being
behind bars.
Wow.
Hunched down with a swollen eye in
front of two shirtless young man.
One of them was holding the leash.
Berries told family members that he was
jumped by 10 other inmates and guards
couldn't check on him until
six hours after the incident.
Well,
investigating.
Believe the incident was gang related.
Oh my God.
She wants to.
Sure it's from the department that he
will be able to pay his debt to society
without being killed.
Look at that killed picture.
Look at that picture.
Be fucked up.
Let me get a look at that picture.
Holy Shit.
That's scary.
Imagine being that guy
and that's your life.
Back that up.
Jamie said,
I don't mean to laugh,
but there be a worse scenario.
Look at that,
man.
That is crazy.
That's as high as theirs.
There's a Bersin picks it you
don't want on the Internet,
but that's the worst.
It's the worst picture of all time.
If he that guy,
how crazy is that to have a Dick pick up?
Well,
that's a good picture to deter
people from committing crimes.
You're actually,
it's a good picture to show that
people learn when you put them in jail.
They really change.
They change their ways.
They don't continue.
Bang.
The guys pulling the
trigger at the camera.
The other guy's throwing up a gang sign
and he's got a leash around a dude who's
got a fucked up face.
You don't know that's a gang sign.
That could be Mork and Mindy
could be really like star Trek.
Could we start track?
You just live long and prosper science.
Fuck God.
That guy on the bottom it.
He's just like,
fuck.
That's a crazy way to live.
That's a crazy way to live,
man.
This poor guy has got to live like that
for six hours until the guards come and
chase him and then what happens?
Does he do they put him in solitary?
Yeah,
he's probably hoping.
that's best case scenario
would be if he does,
he's going to have to do
his whole time in solitary.
Andy defrain out of bad homeboys.
Fucking he's in some shit.
Any differing from Shawshank redemption.
Fight off the lady boys.
Wow.
Powerful.
Strange reference.
Shush all I reference this movie.
That's hilarious.
How he,
how do you have time to train,
watch all these movies and then know
every God damn fight like an encyclopedia.
You watch fights twice there.
All you need to do is watch him once,
uh,
usually once,
once.
And you remember,
you got to remember,
I do those shows for fight pass EOC now.
So I,
I research a lot of shit.
Okay?
Okay.
There's a dude,
there's another photo of him.
One is I all fucked up.
We get them on the left.
Good Times.
We get them in the right.
[inaudible] your Dick in the,
I choked him to sleep.
It says,
Oh,
you do.
Who knows?
It says a gang related,
aggravated battery robbery and theft of
a motor deficits jumped by 10 people.
Fuck man.
It's terrifying.
Being in jail and,
and knowing that you're in jail with a
bunch of other prisoners and that there's
no one watching out for you,
no one protecting you.
That's the terrifying
thing about being in jail.
Do you fight back or do you just like,
you know what,
fuck it.
Tear this out.
You have to decide whether
or not it's worth it.
You could die and if you don't die,
you know,
you could be unbelievably injured to
the point where you're never the same
person again.
Or You could just deal with their shit
for eight years and succumb and then get
out and never be the same person again.
Cause you're always been,
you've been diminished by a bunch of men
who have you down and you'll have PTSD.
If there's 10 guys that your
fight 100% you're a fight.
You know,
who knows what happens in your mind if
you know you're never getting out of
there.
I agree.
That's a different animal.
You got to think like,
this is my new world.
I have to figure out how I handled
was told you up and you knew it was
inevitable that they got you.
They got your hog tied and they're
ready to go in the ass too.
You want to use,
you want to go dry syrup or
jelly or peanut butter or,
or you're all in spit or your own spit.
You could spit on there.
His hands.
Yes.
What do you want?
Dry Dry.
Was there the Syrup Jelly,
Jelly.
All data,
Jelly carry all day.
Is it raspberry jelly,
but it's going to be in your
asshole [inaudible] prison jelly.
So it's going to be those
raspberry containers.
You know what I mean?
That little lip,
you know?
I know,
but raspberry has those
little seeds that lubricate,
you know,
you're an asshole a little bit.
I feel it's kind of fucked up that they
take people like in jail and they make
them be around other people
that are also with no,
everyone is at their
youngest most horniest crate,
which I liked a lot.
A lot of violent criminals between age
of 19 and 23 like there's been studies
done.
Brian,
cal and I were talking about this on the
last podcast that we did from the car
that if you,
uh,
if you removed all the 19 to 23 year old
males in our society of violent crime
would drop by like 90% shit.
Some crazy number who came up with that?
They just did studies on the amount of
people that commit violent crimes and
when they committed the crimes,
the age for V for young males,
it's very,
very high.
But they always say when in the
prison system you go in with whatever,
you know your bachelors of crime and you
come out with your master's master's.
Yeah.
They always say that.
Yes,
you're around other criminals
who know their shit man.
And it's not like you're going in
and you're learning positive shit.
It's becomes your culture too.
Yes.
You get out.
A lot of guys are habituated
where they get out in there,
fuck,
they don't know how to like hang
out and be afraid of the world.
What a shitty system and the fact that
someone could do one of those and make
money and then you find out there's guys
like that judge in Pennsylvania that
was luck in young kids up and have
juvenile just to get the money.
He was getting kickbacks from the prison.
Fuck man.
So he was taking kids in,
railroading them and sending them down
river and making money off of a holy
fuck.
One kid committed suicide and his mother
was at the trial screaming at the guy.
It was dark.
I get put away forever.
Forever.
How did they bust some shit on?
No,
it's a good question.
That is so fucked up.
That story bothered me so much.
I didn't even want to read into it.
The idea that some guy had a lot though,
isn't that the private
prisons and all that shit?
Well that is a specific case when
they're talking about juvenile offenders.
This guy was selling,
selling,
sending juveniles that were innocent
to like these detention camps.
How much was he making?
I don't know him that nothing.
He did it.
He made hundreds of thousands
of dollars over a period.
Then he went to jail.
Fuck yeah,
they're gonna.
They're gonna fuck him up.
He's fucked.
The idea that a judge put people in
jail for money and now he's in jail.
They're gonna fuck that guy up.
That guy might not ever,
he might not make it.
He shouldn't.
I agree.
I mean that's Karma.
That's justice.
You ruined kids lives.
You take them into your there and you
stuff them in with kids like those guys
and they do something like that to them.
And then you have guys like two
thousand ten thousand fucking dead.
Oh my God created fake this.
This guy went to jail because he created
a fake humorous myspace page about her.
Is Her school's vice principal 12 cursed
at a another student's mother 17 did
nothing at all.
It didn't matter,
man.
Kids for cash is a documentary.
Oh my goodness.
Called kids for cash.
Your documentary on Netflix,
I'm sure.
I don't know.
Oh my God.
He made 2.2 million.
Ooh.
As a finder's fee for the
construction of a for profit facility,
which houses so-called delinquents.
Oh my God.
He sentenced around 3000
children in a similar matter.
Oh my God,
I should go to prison just to
get ass raped every morning.
Well,
he's doing 28 years,
which means he could probably
get out and less than that,
but most likely you won't make it.
God,
no,
that's fucked in there.
My God.
What a fucking piece of shit.
That guy is the idea that a human
being could do that to a kid though.
Crazy,
Huh?
It's just terrifying.
It's just terrifying that that
someone would have that in there.
Their DNA,
they have that in their brain
where they can accept that.
And then you have guys like,
you see that documentary?
The Jinx on Hbo Has Holy Shit.
Robert Durst,
who,
who got away with murder,
he chopped dude's limbs
off and his head off,
he got busted.
He
admitted he killed the guy,
but he says,
Hey,
I kill.
I had to do that because
I accidentally killed him.
I didn't think anybody
was going to believe me.
So I thought,
hmm,
I better chop off all his limbs in
his head and throw him in the river.
And he got off to the money because
he said it was self defense.
It was caught up with him,
but he didn't call the cops.
He just as a side and nobody
was going to believe him.
So he had to chop the dude
up and he got away with it.
God damnit.
So crazy.
Totally get.
And on top of that,
when they first arrested him,
did you saw it right?
Yeah.
When they first arrested him,
uh,
he posted bail and skip town.
So he was a fugitive down.
What the fuck?
They finally catch him,
catch him and shot him some money.
They catch him shoplifting,
he's said,
and he's a millionaire.
Murdered the guy and chopped him up.
But he said he,
he did it because he didn't think people
were going to believe him because his
wife was missing and they think he did.
It
went missing.
His wife went,
Miss [inaudible] says wife went missing.
He killed his best friend.
His,
his wife went missing.
They never found the body.
So for 10 years,
her family suspected,
and they knew he did it
because she was always saying,
he's going to kill me.
He's going to kill him.
He's gonna fuck me up.
He's going to kill me.
And then one night she disappeared
and he had an alibi or you know,
she never showed up or she came and I
dropped her off at the train and I don't
know where she went.
We were having a lot of trouble,
so maybe she just left me,
you know,
people just leave,
and uh,
so they never found the body,
so they just let it go.
And he's,
he's an air of like a gazillionaire
own skyscrapers in New York.
Yeah.
He had a lot of power,
a lot of money.
And he got away with
making his wife disappear.
They still haven't found the body.
They think there's
another case too from the,
I'm a health food store in Vermont.
There was a girl who's
working in that town.
A young girl disappeared.
That's another one.
They didn't talk about it,
but it came out after there's a new one,
they're connecting to him.
Whoa.
That might have been
the first one he killed.
That was one of the greatest
documentaries I've done.
Last one's insane.
When he goes to the bathroom,
he's a way to go like talking
to himself like an asshole.
He got,
I killed him.
Of course they got me.
Of course he's like talking,
he doesn't realize that Mike is still
in the bath talking to himself confess
because I busted him that
that's the evidence though.
Like his,
his uh,
lawyers like,
dude,
if you think that's enough
evidence we can go try right now.
I'm going to shit all over your story.
Cause that what they're
saying and he's like,
what about the letter that the killer
wrote to the police department?
It's his writing too.
That was great.
Have you seen it?
Do you see?
You never see it.
You never see a guy go like a,
you know,
in true romance and they
talked about Panama's.
When people lie,
if you,
if you ask them a question,
Dereck,
and they lie,
if they're lying,
there's like things they do,
they scratch their head or there's
like a tick when they answer,
there's something girls
have like 13 things they do,
guys have nine,
something like that.
And uh,
and that's what people at like,
uh,
detectives,
that's what they look for.
That's what they keep asking questions
and they just have a camera on your face.
They review the camera.
That's how they see if you're lying,
you're twitches.
And Man,
when they said,
is this your riding?
He goes,
yes,
that's my writing.
And it was boom,
boom.
It was blocking his face,
goes,
walked the talk.
He goes like this.
No,
he started gagging cause
this you're writing.
He goes,
he knows Bourbon Yankees.
Like,
Oh God,
no.
Oh,
does this too.
This is the ultimate,
this is usually what
they look for is like,
what were you that last night?
Well,
how was,
you know,
and I was um,
and,
uh,
um,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck I will,
you know what I mean?
You're doing all these things.
He went like this,
he went like this
and then the Gulf and then the
burping and when he's in the bathroom,
why did you burp the burden of pain?
He's like,
it's so obvious talking himself.
Oh my God,
it's so crazy.
But he had the pressure
of gliding that long.
Must be overwhelming,
man.
He must've been a smart dude.
Cause so many investigators came after
me at the same story over and over.
But the thing that fucked him is the
way spelled Beverly Beverly hills,
he spelled it with an extra e.
So the killer killed a
lady and sent the letter,
said the cadavers here with,
uh,
the address and he spelt Beverly with
an extra e white killed the chick.
Well,
he,
it was all about his wife.
He made his wife disappear.
So for 10 years he got away with it.
But he had a really,
his best friend with some chick who
was the daughter of a big mob boss.
So he was really connected with the mob.
So that was the only chick who knew she
was his publicist during the 10 years
when people were accusing him,
they ended up dropping the case.
They could never find a body.
So she knew.
She ended up moving to fucking la.
She was a writer.
They still kept in touch,
but her,
the wife who was missing her family
would always tell the investigators goal,
interview,
that chick,
Sharon something,
go interview that chick.
That chick knows go question.
And then when they were finally
going to do at 10 15 years later,
they were going to reopen it
and go question that chick.
He's in New York,
she's dead.
She gets blown away and it just so happens
he flew to California like that name,
but he was a northern cal because I was
in northern California and they track
them driving down cause he would,
they track,
you can't.
He goes,
I was in California.
but you,
you can't put me in La.
Why is he have any kids?
People all the time.
Well,
where are you doing in California
to California's a big state.
Yes.
Oh,
but the thing is,
it all stems from,
I guess his dad was,
he had like four or five brothers and
sisters and his mom committed suicide,
jumped off the top of the
House with the dad goes,
your mom's about to do
some only wakes him up,
brings him to the window.
Like look at your mom.
The mom commit suicide,
jumps off dark right in front of him.
He said,
your mom's about to do something,
so you want us to watch that.
He wakes up.
He's the only kid he wakes up,
grabs him and goes,
check out your mom out there.
And he's like,
what?
He's wanted his mom.
You want to just send them
to see was what he said.
But all his defense was always
about feel sorry for me.
I,
you know,
for Siphon it was all,
that's what,
just kidding.
That's what he said.
He was real shit.
It be create a monster.
If his dad killed his mom in front
of them were really what it was.
What it was is he got rid of his,
his wife.
So the only reason he murdered that
check was cause she was going to start
talking 10 15 years later.
So he had to kill it.
What about the neighbors?
So he killed her,
the neighbor because then he kills her
and then he disappears and dresses up
like a chicken.
Rents a house in Arizona or mute chick
in Texas so that no one talks to me.
He's like an old lady.
So after he kills her,
he's in Texas hiding out and he had
this neighbor that eventually he started
talking to after a while and then he,
he ended up telling him who he was and
then he had to kill him too because he
knew like it was just really obvious.
He looks like shit because
he knew he was killing it.
How's he getting away with this?
He looks like a piece of shit.
Yeah,
he looks like Mr. Burns Bro.
It's like Mr. Burns just
shooting and killing anybody.
He's chopping bitches up
to and then check this out.
That would be,
that would take four.
So the neighbor that he told every,
he,
his wife disappeared.
Beautiful,
great,
great skin.
And so he has to kill his neighbor
in Texas because he knows everything.
So he chocked,
he chops up,
has he chops off his arms,
his legs in his head.
He puts them in plastic bags,
he throws him in the leg.
The next morning he comes to see if
they float it up and they floated up.
So it's like fuck all these
body parts right there.
So he says,
fuck it.
He grabs the head cause he shot him
in the head and disappeared with that.
They never found the head.
They found the body.
Obviously they check the fingerprints.
They went to the guys,
they went to the guy's house,
they started interviewing the,
the landlord and the neighbor go,
who lives here?
They go,
some mute old lady.
Then they started,
then they figured out,
oh shit,
this is the dude that fucking did it.
He gets busted,
he gets arrested,
post bail disappears.
They catch him shoplifting a
sandwich like a week later.
So then he goes to trial,
he goes to trial,
but he was wanted for the murder for that
lady in California and still his wife.
But Texas said he's
willing to try him here.
We got them open and shut.
He's done.
He was done,
dude.
He,
there was no way he was going to get.
Don't say any more.
I want to watch this fucking thing.
No,
but it's not.
But they literally,
but it isn't about that.
It's not about that you,
they tell you all that time,
done this whole story on the
podcast several times though.
We have ReGenX.
Who was it that talked about it?
Tom Score.
Total whole story.
All right.
Not as,
not as in within the
ASM as do you know what?
Not Man,
you're an entity.
I feel like you've seen
him multiple times.
I gotta be honest.
I saw once,
cause there's six parts,
six hours,
six hours straight is six hours here.
Just go to the nuts dude.
HPO fucking rules that HBO go.
Hbo Go get the fuck you just called Pi.
I,
I'm not a big fan of old music at all.
Frank Sinatra was like,
I don't give a fuck about Frankston.
I watched,
did you watch that documentary?
A big Frank Sinatra fan house war
fucking hat because his story,
it's fucking God damn.
He was huge.
He got huge,
really quick like in the
forties and was massive.
Left his wife and two
kids married Ava Gardner,
like the,
like the Angela Angelina
Jolie at the time,
as soon as he married her,
his career went to shit.
The labels dropped him.
The movies he had no one wanted to
do movies with them cause he just,
no,
because it was just a new time.
Elvis came in and it was
a new times are drunk too.
He's fucking up.
He was,
he was,
he was fucking everything.
He was just a white self
sabotage a little bit.
He was in the,
in the early fifties he was washed up,
dude,
he was done.
Ava Gardner is trying to
fucking get away from time.
She's good.
She's doing movies in Europe,
trying to get away,
and he's on plane
Stockinger and going after.
And she,
she loved him,
but she was done with them.
And so at the,
he was rock bottom and he read
this script from here to eternity.
I don't know how I got the script,
but he,
that was a part in from here to eternity
that he thought he could play a nail.
And he begged the studio,
please give me one more chance.
I could do this.
And then they didn't want to do it.
So Ava Gardner calls it,
puts the call in and says,
just give him a shot.
He put through,
you know what he did for three grand?
So he did it,
dude.
And while he was making the movie,
everybody knew that the movie was
going to be big and then frank,
so I'm just going to make a big comeback.
So with that heat,
capitol records signed them
and gave them another chance.
So the movie comes out,
he went to the fucking Oscar and his
new album that came out fucking blew up.
So now he's a hundred times
bigger than he's ever been.
He's a monster.
Start his own record company.
Start his own movie company.
Matt Hill saw anymore.
I'll watch that story is just
bravo.
Do you see going clear watch ology Jesus.
Yes.
The science you see going clear.
So I told you I read some of the book.
That shit is insane.
It's amazing.
It's not talking about that.
I don't want to get followed in shit.
No,
I'm sorry.
I converted that and I
converted to Christianity is
way crazier than Scientology
itself.
Fucking girl on a bearded guy up in the
clouds or an alien that takes you out of
a volcano.
Yeah.
What?
It's,
what's worse?
What's worse is the guy who was obviously
mentally ill created this religion.
Well obviously I think he was brilliant.
There you go.
You know he wrote more
books than anybody ever.
Yeah.
He would publish more books than
anybody knows how close they're so bad.
You could write them in a day.
That's why.
Have you ever read battlefield earth?
Absolutely.
Another right shadow field
or and say that about LRA.
Ooh,
are you?
If you look at the,
if you watch the movie,
it's,
it's a fucking amazingly bad movie.
It's a movie with John
Travolta and forest Whitaker.
Forest Whitaker plays
giant alien John Travolta.
It's,
it's,
so,
it's the worst movie ever,
right?
It's not the story I've heard.
It seems like a sketch and Saturday
night live like a parody of a really bad
science fiction film.
This is it.
It's so bad.
John Travolta defends it.
How dare he,
and this is all based on an
l Ron Hubbard book about,
you know,
alien invaders and do their saints from,
she wants to get out,
but they have too much dirt on them.
Um,
who says that this documentary,
he can't get out now son.
It's too late.
You're too deep too,
man.
They scare me to convince.
Confess all your shit and they record it.
That's what they blackmail.
That's how they get you Cruz's
balls deep in it allegedly.
Yeah.
It's also a gang.
What Gang?
They'll protect you.
I had to pick a religion to be
totally 100% devoted to and be real.
It would be Scientology.
Fuck off.
It would be.
They,
well,
they have a lot of the things you like
to know what they did this and killing
people.
No,
no.
But you know what?
They real estate,
the IRS make them after the IRS,
all the Scientologists got together
because IRS was going to bury him for
billions and billions of dollars
because of some back taxes.
They weren't paying taxes.
And they're saying,
cause ever saying,
hey,
we're religion.
Fuck you guys.
Where religion,
just like all your other religions.
So the IRS said you will
not a fucking religion.
This is not over that you
owe $5 billion in taxes.
So what they decided to do is
they filed each one of them,
all the Scientology.
I'll filed lawsuits against the
IRS and went after different people
individually.
They all do.
So they flooded them.
So they're like,
oh shit,
how do we make this shit go away?
Just make us a religion,
make a fucking year religion.
And they need done some Worsley shit.
That's,
that's powerful and insane.
But the guy that took over after he died,
I forget his name is
Scott Bitch or something.
It's like Tom Cruise.
Ooh,
that guy's intent and you see all this
shit that they wrote about all the people
that were in going clear like
all the character assassinations.
Oh,
really?
See CVC,
Scientology response to going,
oh,
there's two.
Sure.
There's two sides to every story.
I just want to make it really clear.
If I had to pick a religion,
I would pick Scientology and
that's all I'm going to say.
You're crazy.
You're fucking bad ass Tom
Cruise movie documentary though.
Seems like it's a good one
to be in show business.
Yes.
Right.
You get to hang out with Tom Cruise
and John Travolta dude from us 70 show.
The guy with the frog.
Jenna Elfman.
Fuck yeah,
there's a lot of cool.
They party harm and Greg,
they party hard.
I thought I don't even drink.
I thought that I don't drink.
Ooh,
I didn't know that.
Odd.
Is that true?
I heard they have savage
parties with sex parties.
You know what?
I don't.
I know about Mormons.
I might've made that up.
I might be confused.
Get my cults mixed up.
I know.
It's tough.
They're all cult.
I'm eating.
Let's wrap this bitch up.
Let's do it.
We just did a four hour podcast.
I'm Paul close to it.
Right.
I'm proud of you.
Two guys showed awesome stamina down.
We've got cardio to wrap this up.
Mirko Cro cop is a bad motherfucker.
Hell yeah.
Mirko Cro,
cop respect.
That's one of the greatest
fights of all time right there.
That was impressed.
That's intense.
Eddie.
I was one of the greatest,
come on come rematch.
He's getting his ass kicked.
We gave up on him.
It was over.
It was fucking,
oh he mounted him.
Why he's beaten.
Mounted him twice.
He cut them open in,
in hindsight he should have went for
that arm more diligently and made,
he should have finished
him for the amount of shit.
You don't camp out on a mountain
and you finish the fight.
The quickest way to finish the issues.
Yeah.
Cause that's what it happens a lot.
It happens a lot more than you think.
A guy amount of guy and then
the next round he gets knocked.
What's next for Cro cop for?
We had,
um,
I don't know man,
but I think that's a good word.
If he just goes on a revenge tour,
he's like,
I want to kill Brendan.
Ooh.
And he was going to go back to
the gym in here in two weeks.
Yeah.
He's fucked up.
I don't know.
Yeah,
he did two weeks ago.
I think it took some hits to the face.
He decides to go out on that high note.
I ain't going to hate him.
Right.
I hope he does.
Why not seem keep fighting until he loses.
That's a great flight to go out of hell.
Yeah.
That's,
that would be kind of a movie.
That's a girl time.
Great ending.
Yeah.
It's like a Clint Eastwood movie.
Yup.
And then boom,
the credits were all right there.
It's not going to happen that way.
But yeah,
I like it.
The crazy thing is we didn't
totally given up on him.
You know,
when he was getting mounted
and he's getting beat up or it,
Goddamn Gonzaga was just,
his Jujitsu is too good.
You know the name of your documentary?
The name of the movie as good cop,
Cro,
cop.
I'm not mad at that.
All right.
I'm just throwing that out there.
Another documentary?
No,
come on.
Give it up.
How good.
He's fucking pro bars.
We don't even sell.
All these songs
are so fucking with him and I've
told people not to eat on camera.
Wasn't he a policeman?
He was a policeman.
Oh,
that's right.
That's why it's,
why call him Cro.
Cop Cro.
Cop.
Well,
he's anti,
he's in the antiterrorist terrorism team.
Yeah.
And Croatia.
And he's on government now.
He's on the still pretty sure
that the fuck is he trained.
I think you just kick shit nonstop.
It's like iron sheik baby in a suit.
Iron sheik documentaries.
Amazing.
Don't know that's on Netflix.
So aren't,
she'd done a documentary Jenks
the jinx on Hbo going clear.
Hpl what was the other one lady?
Valid frankly about Frank
Sinatra is a documentary.
Yeah.
What's that about?
That's the navy seals.
Seal turns.
Lady vowel.
You guys making documentaries out there?
I fucking love documentaries.
Joe Loves Him.
Everybody loves documentaries.
You got the title.
Has to tell you what the
documentary is about.
Don't get all artsy cause
I don't have time to go.
I'm just flipping through
documentaries man.
And I'm like,
that could be great.
I don't know what it's about,
but I don't have time.
Right.
That looks great.
I don't have time to go to the info.
It's got to tell you right
there what it's about.
I mean Lady Val is pretty cut and dry.
I went past that a couple times up
the we documentaries.
You know it's a,
we document.
Roger.
Hi.
Hi Business or what does that other one?
Something business.
I don't know.
We'd business in those in those.
Uh,
for some reason the we documentaries,
you know it's a weed though.
There's just like a big,
well the union union was a little weird.
It had a big leaf though.
Yeah.
He can always tell the leaf
this gotta be something.
Don't get all crazy with zero more
recognizable symbol that a company,
a company didn't create.
Then the leaf.
Yeah,
that'll pop.
And he didn't cry.
He didn't create the pot.
Leaf is not like Coca Cola.
Anybody could use the pile leaf,
but is there a more
recognizable symbol that the,
that of the government or
a company didn't create?
How about that upside down pot leaf that,
that's pretty good.
Um,
uh,
tied McCormick cheeses.
You notice that he does the leaf,
the leaf one,
the regular one.
It's,
he does it upside down like
that and it's pretty damn cool.
It looks cool.
UPS It out.
Yeah.
It's cool.
It's still pot leaf.
You can't,
you can't mistake it.
I can't think of anything more.
Plenty of another iconic shape.
I'm going to smoke weed.
I don't smoke.
I'm just worried about my lungs.
Man.
What have you found out that
it's good for your lungs?
If you did,
what if he did?
What did it,
what if there was some evidence
that you could read and said,
Oh shit.
And actually cleans your lungs.
You just fucked up and went into a dark
hole of Eddie Bravo talking to you about
pot.
I'm just curious.
You didn't even understand what
you're about to experience.
Well,
no,
but I'll kill it right here
if the UFC sanctions it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
You're have one day
going shit before the UFC.
Really?
It helps head trauma that
kind of fell smoking.
Oh Damn.
Because they see the benefits
from these concussed dudes.
All right,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
Brennan shop on Twitter.
Joe Rogan on Twitter.
Um,
Eddie,
anything to tell people where
to go with c 10th planet,
J J.
Dot.
Com Harlow fighter and the kid podcast,
the Eddie Bravo radio podcast.
Birches thank you for everybody that
tuned in and hope you guys enjoyed it.
We always love doing,
these are a lot of fun.
So that's it.
See you fuckers later.
Bye Bye.